bonjour à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors cette question
d'avoir ce qu'on a véritablement les
moyens justement de prendre en charge
d'aider les entreprises à ce point tel
que l'a annoncé hier à emmanuel macron
par exemple chômage partiel prises en
charge à 100%
oui tout à fait il faut tout faire pour
que deux entreprises survivent puisque
ce sont nos unités de proscrire de
production ce sont les organisations
humaines qui nous permettent de produire
donc il faut autant idées les salariés
que les employeurs il ya aucun souci
là-dessus et on a les moyens de le faire
plutôt que de créer de la monnaie pour
les marchés financiers de la spéculation
comme l'a fait la banque centrale
européenne vous l'avez remarqué dans
votre journal avec 120 ya autant de
faire pour aider l'économie réelle c'est
beaucoup plus intelligente et juste donc
selon vous la décision de la bce
d'injecter 120 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir les marchés
soutenir les banques ce n'est pas une
décision qui va vraiment changer ça se
passe dans l'essonne c'est un scandent
sais tu sais tu c'est une honte c'est à
dire qu'on met 120 milliards d'euros
d'argent public pour soutenir des
marchés financiers qui les gens les plus
riches n'ont pas besoin de ça quoi c'est
l'économie réelle qu'il faut soutenir et
certainement pas les marchés financiers
de toute manière on ne résoudra cette
crise qui est économique que quand on
aura résolu la crise sanitaire
or on voit très bien qu'on à 2800 cas
aujourd'hui
si on continue ainsi dans un mois on
multiplie par dix toutes les semaines on
aura 28 millions de cas ça se passera
pas parce qu'on prendra les mesures et
donc on est en train de prendre un
risque absolument énorme avec la santé
des français
c'est absolument inconséquent
irresponsable monsieur macro prend des
décisions extrêmement fait pour arrêter
la crise sanitaire qui est le problème
principal
avant la crise économique et donc
pourtant on a la leçon de l'italie qui a
fait les mêmes mesures que nous il ya
dix jours qui n'a pas du tout réussi à
arrêter l'épidémie
et journaliste français les politiques
italiens appellent notre gouvernement à
être réaliste il ne fait rien on ne
comprend pas ils responsables
incompétents cynique on peut se poser la
question
s'agissant des des bourses
il ya on a observé un rebond ce matin
après le krach boursier d'hier que ce
qu'il faut en penser
franchement c'est très compliqué de
savoir parce que la bourse et dans un
mécanisme de bulles comme en 99
vous voyez à tel point qu'elle montait
de 10% pendant le mois de février
alors même que la crise du conte au
renard virus était évidente et allez
allez nous frapper et frapper la chine
en cassant les chaînes de production
donc les marchés sont devenus
complètement irrationnelle parce qu'ils
sont dopés d'argent public parce que la
priorité des politiques ce sont les
marchés financiers avant les humains
donc on peut pas vraiment vous dire ce
qui va se passer c'est trop compliqué il
y a un plan encore plus scandaleux je
suis désolé de dire ça mais il faut dire
les choses un moment donné l'argent
public devrait être utilisé pour acheter
des actions
c'est ce qui se murmure de plus en plus
notamment par l'ancien numéro deux de la
banque centrale et on voit donc on est
dans un système économique complètement
corrompue au service des milliardaires
et non pas au service de la population
de lutte contre l'épidémie
j'en suis désolé mais c'est la situation
est absolument scandaleux ce tant du
point de vue économique que du point de
vue sanitaire
et s'agissant des perspectives
économiques à venir sur du court moyen
terme
impossible à prévoir là dessus la chine
dit qu'elle est guérie
c'est tout à fait possible d'autant plus
qu'elle envoie des respirateurs en
italie donc ça doit lier mieux chez elle
donc la chaîne de production ira mieux
là bas mais on ne sait pas parce que
tant qu aura pas de traitement contre le
virus le virus peut passer 2009 il sert
nord à l'hémisphère sud d'un pays à
l'autre
donc ça va être une crise extrêmement
complexes à régler au niveau économique
ce qu'il faut faire c'est faire tenir
les gens faire tenir les entreprises
pour que nos outils de production ne
soit pas détruite c'est ça qui est
fondamental j'ai impossible de prévoir
ce qui va se passer c'est le chaos
merci beaucoup à vous un philippe maurer
j'appelle que vous êtes économiste
merci